all right we're going to turn now to the
new efforts to restore confidence in the
troubled banking sector all in the wake
of the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank
two Banks were bought over the weekend
by Rivals after running into difficulty
Signature Bank for 2.7 billion dollars
and Credit Suisse for just over 3
billion sounds like a lot of money and
it is but it's a lot less than they were
worth before this Crisis began and we're
also learning more about the risky moves
by Silicon Valley Bank which had been
reportedly under Federal review for
years at O'Keefe has more on all of it
Ed Good morning Tony good morning that
buyout by Credit Suisse not being
treated well by stock markets overnight
in Asia and Europe banking stocks are
down and all of this comes as members of
both parties say there needs to be more
accountability for Bank regulators
we need accountability for our
Regulators who clearly fell down on the
job and that starts with Jerome Powell
Massachusetts Democratic Senator
Elizabeth Warren is calling out the
Federal Reserve chairman and a regional
body charged with bank oversight why
didn't the Chief regulator in Silicon
Valley area the San Francisco Federal
Reserve Act here do you have confidence
in its president Mary Daly
no I do not and the Republican chair of
the house Financial Services committee
says all options should be on the table
to prevent a further crisis we need to
get to the bottom of whether or not this
is a supervisory problem a regulatory
problem a bank mismanagement problem
perhaps all three and and all and all in
all frankness it comes as the Wall
Street Journal reports the Federal
Reserve had been looking into allegedly
risky practices at Silicon Valley Bank
going back to 2019 and the New York
Times reports a Fed review of svb in
2021 flagged that the firm was doing a
bad job of ensuring that it would have
enough easy to tap cash on hand in the
event of trouble but the bank didn't
address those issues as it ballooned in
size the Swift and stabilizing solution
was absolutely necessary over the
weekend there was yet another
government-backed takeover of a bank
this time in Europe the Swiss government
helped broker a deal allowing UBS to buy
credit Suites a bank plagued with
Scandal and mismanagement for years for
about three billion dollars the biggest
bank shakeup since the 2008 financial
crisis
meanwhile President Biden's calling for
new legislation that would hold top Bank
Executives more accountable among other
things he wants a federal bank
Regulators to be able to Bar those
Executives from working in the banking
industry if their bank is taken over by
the federal government the next big
thing to watch this week is what the
Federal Reserve decides to do about
interest rates there had been some hope
Vlad that they would hold off but
experts believe they'll be raising them
again
all eyes on the FED Ed as always we
thank you